un drama sobre los hospitales en francia
y la película más sulfurosa del 2021
sacudieron la alfombra roja del festival
de calles
la directora francesa catherine corsini
cuenta en la fractura
una noche caótica en un hospital
parisino durante una manifestación de
los chalecos amarillos contra emmanuel
rafa y julie una pareja al borde de la
ruptura acude a un servicio de
emergencia a punto de colapsar allí
conocen al colérico iván un camionero
herido en una manifestación de los
chalecos amarillos quien continúa
gritando en el hospital sin descontento
contra el presidente y el gobierno
francés es la fractura es un
largometraje brillante donde se mezclan
historias personales y fracturas
sociales y también es un homenaje al
personal hospitalario afectado por los
cortes de presupuesto antes de la
pandemia del coronavirus
él siempre transgresor director holandés
paul verhoeven levantó una ola de
expectativa aquí en cannes con benedetta
un drama sobre una monja lesbiana en el
siglo 17 estatal como son benedict
actual la actriz belga virginie efira
prestó su agraciado físico para
interpretar a esta monja italiana que
descubre los placeres de la carne cuando
se apresta a ser beatificada tras un
presunto milagro el veterano paul
verhoeven firma aquí un largometraje
místico entre escándalo y sensualidad
basado en la historia verdadera de esta
monja condenada a la hoguera por
homosexualidad cepa como un estado de
sus crisis tengo que cumplir se
pronuncia todavía más
si no hace descubrir
en esta familia
[Música]